the human condition
[Music]
is no small picnic
we are uniquely aware
which is both our blessing and our curse
we have the mental capacity as ernest
becker said to ponder the infinite
seemingly capable of anything
yet we're housed in these heart-bumping
breath-gasping
decaying bodies
we are gods
and we are worms
and so there is a faint disquiet
that haunts our dreams even our greatest
ecstasies are tinged
by a bit of sadness by a bit of turmoil
by the existential
grief
and paralyzing realization that all is
transient and that one day we will die
and how to make sense and how to
assimilate
and how to make peace with the disquiet
so that we may function with some kind
of equanimity in the face of such a
burden
upon the psyche
ernest becker said that
the full realization of the human
experience is one in which the only
response is full and open psychosis
this is the reason why
we are in an epic
epidemic mental health
situation in the world today because
we have materially secured our needs
which has only deepened the wounds and
needs of our psyches which cannot be
swashed or accommodated into personal
extinction
we have emerged out of nothing to have a
name consciousness of self deep inner
feeling and excruciating inner yearning
for life and self-expression and with
all this
yet to
[Music]
it's die difficult right we know we are
gods we make manifest and engender our
imagination we exteriorize our
creativity we instantiate the renderings
of mind the man-made world is the
condensation of human imagination said
parents mckenna look at us
dazzling alchemists right the coral
reef-like animal the extruder of
technological material right we take in
matter of low organization we put it
through the filters of the human mind
and we extrude
magnificent renderings of our inner
landscape made manifest outside
we turn our insides out this is who we
are this is what we are
how can we simultaneously wither away
age and die
we are the species that can sing the
songs that orchestrate the universe and
we are the species that has to take a
[ __ ] once a day
sitting on a
toilet surrendering our dignity
to
waste
okay so
what to do what to do what to do right
we're in a festival a desert landscape a
demolition derby of reality constructs
colliding on a parched void as eric
davis once described burning man
we are beholding
the human condition
we get to explore the maze with 18 rooms
inside that head which is a metaphor for
our own heads so we get to go inside our
own minds and clean that [ __ ] out and
clean the gunk out we get to see
our lenses of perception right
there they are and we see with those
lenses and we see through those lenses
but we don't see the lenses themselves
unless we are cracked open
unless we uh
are slapped by awe
a moment of such reverie and
enthrallment that you bump up a level
and all of a sudden the lenses you see
through and with
you actually see
now that i'm seeing the lenses i'm
seeing how they inform my world
my lenses determine what i see
i don't see the world as it is i see it
as i am
or rather i see it through my lenses so
can i dispense of those lenses can i
relinquish those lenses can i smash
those lenses can i upgrade those lenses
can i lease a new pair of lenses can i
summon new lenses with an app on my
iphone the point being i've seen another
place to plant my feet there is another
way to see the world there is another
way to operate there is another way to
give our gifts there is another way to
make a contribution
and perhaps this is the most noble the
most noble of responses to our situation
we may be
we may be flawed and stumbling primates
but when we work together
we are primates that can fly
and manifest art and then gender their
imaginations and reprogram biology and
reverse engineer matter and engender of
seventh kingdom of life
kevin kelly's technium
and this capacity to imagine to conceive
the design architect and create in
combination with our modest looking
thumbs as kurzweil said was sufficient
to create a secondary force of evolution
may manifest by our tools and
technologies and artistry
and it will continue
dare i say i hope until the entire
universe is at our fingertips
or as ellen harrington said
we must never forget we are cosmic
revolutionaries
not stooges conscripted to advance the
natural order that kills everyone
so
let us get into it
let us get to it
[Music]
nice one dude